مشكله الجمهوريين في امريكا ليست تحت قبه
الكونجرس فحسب فضائحه بالجمله تدور حول
احد النواب الجمهوريين جورج
[تصفيق]
باسمه عن الساحه السياسيه منذ ديسمبر
الماضي
يبدو ان ماضي النائب الجمهوري كان محطه
اهتمام الديمقراطيين نبشوا في تاريخه احدث
فضائح ليس وليد اللحظه بل يعود لخمسه عشر
عاما مضت حين شارك في مسابقه التي طابع
النسائي وصديقه المقرب هو من كشف سره الا
ان النائب الجمهوريه
الذي انتخب عضو في الكونغرس في انتخابات
نوفمبر النصفيه سبق ان قدم اعتذارا
واعترافا بكذبه في سيرته الذاتيه عده مرات
ويخضع للتحقيق الفيدرالي والمحلي بغض
النظر عن مشاكل سيرته الذاتيه يواجه
تساؤلات عن ثروته وكيف اقرا حملته
الانتخابيه 700 الف دولار وامتلاكه اصولا
بملايين الدولارات وهذا تحول غير بره في
ثروته قائمه طويله من الفضائح السياسيه
تحيط بالنائب الجمهوري قد تكلفه عضويته في
الكونغرس
منها تزوير شهاداته الدراسيه لكن اجباره
على الاستقاله امر محفوف بالمخاطر ستعرض
اغلبيه الحزب الجمهوري الضعيفه بالفعل
للخطر
وتثير شكوكا داخليه بنزاهه النظام السياسي
والمفارقته هذه هي ذات المزاعم التي يبني
عليها الرئيس السابق ترامب منذ خسارته
للرئاسه روان حمزه العربي